hello good afternoon good evening
wherever the hell you are in the world
and welcome to psychecky Sci-Fi TV and
Movie Channel and Mike just called me
the boss I like my day Matthew doesn't
call me the boss if you're on my channel
are you gonna call me the boss no
um
yeah I get no respect from everybody
else off Side Track what have you done
why have you not gotten the respect then
what have you said call me names they're
mean to me
[Music]
um but we are here we're going to talk
about Star Trek and I apologize the
video keeps appearing and reappearing
I've had to delete it twice because of
technical issues that are my own damn
fault but
yeah I'm an idiot what are you gonna do
um so
but anyway how are you sir are you all
right are you ready yeah I'm great it's
uh nice to catch up with you and uh sort
of talk about all things Trek and uh we
had an idea about uh comparisons didn't
we so um tell us more about how you want
to see her well I'm going to run the
little intro and then we'll get into it
[Music]
foreign
there's a couple of people we started
early mate so thank you for being here
and waiting for us but yeah we started
early
um so
my thinking was I was watching something
that basically was talking about the
very classic episode The Pale Moonlight
from Deep Space Nine oh great episode he
was just talking about that and I just
and I'm just sat there thinking that was
a great episode that was an instant
classic and people are still talking
about it 20 years later
um brain pain how you doing sir yeah
five years later well yeah
um and I just got thinking are there
episodes of new Trek that people will be
talking about in 20 years time
and I honestly hand on my heart
I think no
um I actually don't think there are any
at all
but
I am open to have the conversation and I
think I've I think I found two episodes
that maybe we can put into the
conversation and there's Picard season
three that I think we have to put into
the conversation but first of all how
about we talk about a couple of episodes
that I'm actually comparing new track
two okay
um Bob the Star Trek DVD is a commentary
admitting that they wanted to bend Trek
toward the Star Wars crowd and it's
short attention spans well that worked
um so yeah I can see that it really
works and Star Wars and Star Trek are
very different and I love both by the
way I've always said this but they are
very very different beasts very very
different sort of things
in no particular order
um I'm going to start with Star Trek the
Next Generation so let's throw a few
episodes out there that I think we're
into Classics and I've I've done double
episode single episodes doesn't matter
okay and I'm gonna throw the first one
out there The Best of Both Worlds and
for me yeah that was the episode that
that catapulted Star Trek the Next
Generation from good to brilliant I
agree I mean have you ever really seen
anything like that before when it came
out I don't agree it was it was strange
because when it did come out it was
um I think I managed to see both uh
episodes part one or part two rather
than the stage you had to wait about
four months when it was released I think
it's about 1990 it came out of part one
and part two
um and I think you're right when you
first watched it and it was the states
were suddenly so big and so serious
um the it it it's just kind of as you
say it just put the series after that on
a new level and I think even after that
they obsessed when you re-watch it you
you just saw how well written and how
well acted it was and the stakes in what
were involved that as you say it was
just a whole new level and I think the
Next Generation from that point onwards
even though season three was really
something to do well with yesterday's
Enterprise was a good one The Offspring
was another good one The Best of Both
Worlds was where we thought okay this is
where they've really got their act
together the actors all know what
they're doing they're all comfortable
with their roles and after the shaky
first couple of Seasons this is where
everyone starts I mean for me in the
first season the only really episode
that I think touched something and I
don't think it's a great episode but
it's a bloody good episode was
conspiracy conspiracy all the aliens
with the uh
yeah yeah I love that because it's Star
Trek not being very star trekky Captain
Picard and Will Riker standing up aliens
uh
it's such a brilliant episode yeah it
was and also I remember I think that
when it was first on the beach
until it was like edited for the scene
where remix head gets blown up in the
face
there so they edited the chunk out
initially it was banned and this is they
said you can't show that
it's too scary I didn't know that and
and they were allowed to show up but
they have that bit cut out
um so um it was yeah the bit where his
actual face hi Laura the bitter his face
actually like melts off and the little
thing comes out of the neck yeah
you like it
um the season one I liked I like data
law when we first met law I thought I
was quite good episode that was a good
episode yeah and I quite like when no
one has gone before where they literally
go where no one's gone before and like
they went to a place
episode for me this is oh wait look we
we are going to say that there's a lot
of opinion going on here and there's
um so I think with certain episodes I
think people don't argue about that are
brilliant and those are the ones who
want to focus on Best of Both Worlds I
think it's definitely one of those
episodes nobody argues brilliant episode
and if you do argue you're wrong
so um
but
um a couple of other episodes for me
um
oh go original go original Star Trek for
a second go we'll go proper old school
okay what triples
everybody knows that episode everybody
pretty much loves that episode everyone
can name at least two or three bits in
that episode
um if you're a screen is green yes
yeah you've seen it didn't you
um and I would argue again that is was
an instant classic when it came out but
it's still it's still one of the only
few original series episodes that
the city on the internet forever yeah
brilliant that was a good one I'm not
sure it's got a title but one with the
black and white faces that's a great
episode uh let this be your last
Battlefield there you go and
um
uh the oh there's a couple of others
machines one of my favorites Doomsday
Machine which was was great episodes so
I think those were
yeah 100
um I would argue actually that that
those are the those are those are the
shows we should be comparing new track
to oh it's quite tough isn't it yeah
yeah okay I'm a story point of view from
an impact point of view they should have
a similar impact I know maybe it was
easier back then
but I mean we'll compare it to the next
Generation episodes because it's easy as
well so The Best of Both Worlds have
really mentioned
um Peak Performance I think was it was a
brilliant episode was
um what's the one with the
um
there's no one with the headlight it's
not a star case and it was like Riker
was taking come on hey man which one was
it yeah it was that one yeah so they
have to do a battle simulation because
they're prepared yeah
um and
um so after the battle situation a
Ferengi turns up and we do the very
capable Fighters at that point
um
and yeah I mean there's
we saw Riker In a Different Light we saw
Picard In a Different Light
um it's it's one again one of those
episodes that made us think I think the
vessel Leonard is there was was it the
Hathaway or something like that I don't
know Hathaway was in season four
um I can't know what it's called now
maybe it was a halfway
yes it was it was it was the Britain was
the one in season four they're both
um constellation class Starships yes it
was so I'll get rid of geeky with my
ships yeah
I'm sorry you shouldn't say you should
say
um and then for me
the most memed Star Trek episode
ever
and I do where I'm going with this
I need a bit more a bit more there's um
there are five lights
oh God
yeah saying a command is probably the
most memed episode and actually
I mean I would put that
it might be my favorite Star Trek
episode full stop
but if you see that as also like a
precursor to the beginning of Deep Space
Nine it was the first time we saw that
it was literally like the pilot of the
pilot of Deep Space Nine and other than
this another episode of DS9 that I think
is very very similar in the way it
impacted but when we watched
that episode oh God yeah impact of it I
mean you can't I I remember going
I mean Patrick Stewart
this is why because Patrick Stewart has
always been one of the best catches and
the BET one of the best actors to
feature on Star Trek in my opinion and
this is where we put into the test it
was the worst thing since locutus were
born from him for his character yeah and
um and uh and um who was gold is it gold
almost sets who's the actor well-known
actor
he's one of those actors now so he
passed away a couple of years and
everything's correct as well yeah
um he was great as well so um I thought
that was a really really good two-parter
and as I say it was a link to DS9 which
gave it a bit more it was I think it was
showing about a month or two before d
space science pilot and it was just like
okay these are the Kardashians these are
the first time you really see just how
Bloody awful they are and it worked
right and I mean the Federation didn't
really consider the conditions a threat
necessarily but all of a sudden they
were
um
there were a weaker enemy I don't think
they were they were considered a
nuisance perhaps
um I mean obviously it was more of a
nuisance because of the board and the
way the Border thing we had to change
them we had the Maki and I think they
didn't they didn't want to walk they
don't like War but
um
they weren't as the romulans and the
Klingons were the threat and all of a
sudden they're the cardassians were
there going actually now These Guys
these guys are really bad yeah these are
yeah yeah but the acting from
um Patrick Stewart in that episode was
just
I feel like they had to play them
because I really like him I could
picture his face but I can't I can't
tell you his name you know he's one of
those actors that everyone knows his
face but no one knows his name and
Ronnie Cox was in it who of course
appeared in Stargate as Ed Edward
gillico he played the captive from hell
didn't he he came the captain that was
brought in here
he was getting one of the most hated
characters in Star Trek and it was not
fair because he was brilliant
um Captain yeah
yeah it was really good
so but yeah um so I I think that's the
episode but the episode that I think is
most like that from the other two
seasons because I don't think Voyager
ever quite reached that
um height they had some good episodes
and we'll talk about yeah when we get
there I'll tell you what ones I think
did reach quite a high height but I'll
Follow Your Leader but never quite got
that Champions League my God this is a
good you know this is like well I've got
one or two I think
the pale Moonlight with Deep Space Nine
is the other episode that I think is is
very similar in Impact to
um to the uh the the thing I just said
don't chain of command
um in the impact we saw Cisco in a very
different light
the story was very clever
yeah and the way they broke down the
fourth wall
oh
do you watch the episode and you just
sort of sit there for a second and go
wow
so
I mean obviously this is the episode
where Cisco is like living in the 1950s
isn't he and he's um is that the one no
no no no this is one of the romulans
into the Dominion one and it was a sense
of Remax sorry for some reason I think
now this was a very clever episode
because as you say Cisco in this episode
he knows he's going to get dirty to get
the Romans involved and the one person
he knows that can get involved and
actually really help is playing simple
Garrick yeah and so um
is that he starts off with his idea of
right we've got to bring the romulans
into the into the war and he and it just
gets more and more out of control
and Garrick has this idea of of planting
a bomb on the Romulan ship to uh and of
course he has got this uh data chip
which looks like it's some sort of
hidden meeting with the uh with the
Dominion where they think about uh
actually starting the more Runners and
the way they do it is so good it's it's
so powerful and Cisco he starts on the
episode like this love is like he said
I've just done something and the way
they do it and in the end he just
deletes the log it's classic delete
computer delete Pro you know delete log
yeah
and the way he's talking down the screen
he's got his drink there and I like he's
seriously a great actor again
um seriously intense I forgotten
Benjamin Cisco's I do know that his name
Brooks Avery Brooks thank you
um and and yeah he really showed his
acting
skill there and it was a phenomenally
good episode I said that's there's there
are there are a handful
of these episodes that literally when
the credits run
you just have to sit there and just go
and you just have to like to absorb what
you've seen for a second
what was the episode with Cisco where
because I confused it with the name of
this episode where he he thinks he's
living in the 1950s
yeah Benny Russell but I just can't
think of the name of the episode because
I thought that was pretty that was quite
a that was another episode where all the
actors are it's like a fourth wall and
like you see like um you know um
ridiculous because it's so woke now
because it's all about racism and things
as well isn't it yeah yeah but that was
that again I know
it was a high tier one maybe not the
highest but that's the one I thought was
another powerful one I thought there was
a really if we're talking about Good
episodes I think deep I actually think
Deep Space Nine honestly and I'm heart
think despres now is the best of the
three I'm not going to include
Enterprise in that I'm afraid it just
isn't but voyages TNG and D Space Nine
are the are they your top three for me
and Deep Space Nine is just a little bit
but I loved the Dominion Wars I just
loved it
was good it was good sort of thing
um I prefer the characters in TNG I
won't lie and um and I preferred seven
of nine in Voyager yeah Jerry Ryan hello
I I was more of an esri Dax sort of
person
I didn't mind ax but
um I guess I just I'd go with Dax
don't be thinking what's that saying
they said oh yeah okay
let's go with Wilma but I'd be thinking
of Betty yeah that's regrettable yeah
that's what I'm gonna think of it yeah
yeah our American cousins won't get that
reference at all but oh my God that was
a good episode of um
yeah that and back our back was great
but so yeah then you know these are
episodes that go beyond that so okay
then Voyager what episode are you
thinking about are in that top tier
because actually
379 came in Voyager I thought it was
great
one of my favorites is the year of hell
it is a good episode I thought the year
of hell was really powerful because you
know a lot of people
um before and after the series ended
like considering that's it was being
made we're saying but how come Voyager
never kind of like deteriorates how come
he never sort of see it with a scrape
Hall and you know like just looking
deteriorated and it was always fixed at
the end of each episode and back to
normal this episode which I believe was
originally planned to be a whole season
Arc rather than the two passer
um just shows just what happens when
their backs are
against the wall and they're in a
situation they just can't get out of
um I love Kirkwood Smith as anorex I
think he's a great actress in lots of
things I think all the cast really you
know sort of like raise the bar I think
that's one of my favorite episodes or
two passes of gorgeous I think that's a
massive fan of that actually I like um
scorpion Scorpio is a particular
favorite one with yeah four seven two
yeah out of the out of those three
seasons or even Enterprise we can throw
Enterprise into this as well out of the
brown uh yeah period
what was the best finale they were the
best finale
what season finale or series
oh what's the best I
can't as you say scorpion was a season
finale that was a pretty good one I'm
sorry I mean sorry um finale if not the
last yeah so you mean a series okay
um well all good things are called
way to end with the Next Generation and
some of that last
name Poker was again mirrored at the end
of the Picard season three which was a
lovely touch
um the Dominion end of war in DS9 I
think that was pretty good there was a
big lot of space battles it was all
wrapped up Kardashian was pretty much
destroyed Garrett got home finale
sorry it wasn't so you had the two
episodes that wrapped all the Dominion
War up the the actual last episode was
the bit between him and
um Golder cut
it was no it was in the it was all no it
was the war ended in the last episode
the very last episode was Cisco versus
goldacap I oh okay so they I think what
uh a version where the last two episodes
have been made into a finale there's
like a stretch thing
three episodes were the double episode
when they the Dominion war ended and
then Dominion were defeated and then
Cisco returned to Deep Space Nine and
Golden Cut and got another last battle
with the uh and that's when because
Cisco doesn't return does he he doesn't
come back from that no he's not
um it's been a long time I thought they
were together but fair enough
um yeah I liked it
um I don't know
because I I did like the end of the
Dominion war in if it's the previous
episode so but the last episode the last
three episodes so it doesn't make much
difference really but it was all right I
mean I I think it was good it wrapped up
everything well and actually see season
seven the Dominion Ark had the last 10
episodes were all linked together which
was actually good uh what's his oh
definitely was nice okay we'll go with
the Enterprise finale yeah because
everyone hates me we'll talk about that
in a second but yeah
um
[Music]
I think voyages last two episodes was
absolutely brilliant destroying
unimatrix Zero fighting the book again
it was a good Borg episode
um and it actually wrapped up
the story arc really well because there
was a big rumor they're not going to get
home they're going to leave it on a
finale and maybe
I mean would you prefer that would you
have liked it if it was all ended that
they're hopeful they could get home
um and they've got a good way of
potentially getting home but they didn't
get home would you preferred it that way
or the way they did it the way it was
and I think by the time they realized
that they realized they weren't getting
a movie as well which which helped but
um I I like that because I actually
genuinely I will watch it occasionally
and I still go get in when they explode
and they come out of the sphere and I'm
like that blows up yeah yeah it's like
that there was a nice how often do we
actually get a nice finale to a series
that makes sense how often does that
happen
my problem with the finale of that
series is it just felt a bit rushed at
the end we see them and the shape
generally says something like we did it
and then they sort of smile and then we
see the the Voyager turn and the other
ship start to support it to Earth and I
wanted to see well what happened next
what happened to the Marquee who are now
obviously their home would they be
imprisoned would they would they get um
you know let off from their crimes you
know with seven meters it needed
something else just to see how they said
I think they sort of sort of showed that
at the beginning of the two-parter
though in the when you know that future
you mean I know I know it didn't then
technically
happening
yeah it was a wonderful episode the
ending a series is always really really
difficult it's um particularly a big
series like that when there's like a big
overarching story because you've got to
wrap everything up yeah I think that's
one of the best examples of actually a
series getting wrapped up
um just just nice and actually giving
the fans to a degree what they actually
wanted which was just for you to get
home yeah and which a lot of shows they
wouldn't they they're larger they would
have been trying to be clever and they
and they hinted at it they even they
even pushed us right to this was going
yeah we're going to do what we always do
and then they went no no no not really I
got them we're not going to do a scopper
cooler on you he's we're not going to do
any Quantum Leap he's they're good in
the end of that episode there's a scene
where they're in the transport conduit
and seven tonight says look oh we could
go down this can't do it but we might
end up going back to the Delta quad that
wasn't a problem
so there we go
all righty back did it pause for a
second
okay can you see me
am I not there I can't really hear you
Mike my internet might be the issue
though but actually I think it's come
back all right you're a bit fuzzy but
I've had kids here playing Xbox and
things
mine are the same
all right
give it a second
all right all right
[Music]
Zone fly me
right there we go there we go so
um yeah so um what were we saying what
were you saying sorry because I lost you
completely for a minute I think we were
just talking about the end of Voyager
basically and just how it was an
alternate future but they got home and
you sort of like the fact that we saw an
alternate take on how they got home it
actually wrapped it all up lovely yeah
that was great so
um
there were there are a couple of other
voyager episodes I love the void episode
I love in Voyager the way they explored
um again like they did in Deep Space
Nine and they did it just as well really
that um they explored what would happen
to Starfleet and their big ideals when
[__] really hits the fan
um and I always loved that they did that
really well on the void they did that
really well in
um the one that you mentioned the year
of hell yeah yeah
um and and they did that in Deep Space
Nine as well
um the voyagers there lost in this void
of space and they've got two choices
babe basically
um that they can either
um pirate a bunch of other ships and try
to survive what's happening or they can
band together and they end up banding
together and they save the um you know
the uh they end up saving themselves
um I'd like it when we explore the warts
and all version of Star Trek that we
don't always get
it's interesting um I was on site
Fanatics over the weekend and we talked
about Voyager and some of the best
episodes and two of the episodes I liked
or even though they weren't the bigger
biggest Mega kind of explosion things
but for good Sci-Fi Concepts the two
that I like the best are from season two
and they were two vix which I just think
was the purest science fiction Star Trek
conundrum possible problem what do we do
to solve this issue uh with neelix and
tulock as a new being who they discover
we could get in the back but I want to
remain as I am which is just classic
science fiction
um and another one which featured
Michael McKean as the clown which was
the Thor
and I that to me was a really really
powerful it might not be the top tier
you're talking about but just for
remembering just the quality of the idea
the way it was produced the music in it
and and the way it gave me that vibe to
me that these are real maybe not as well
known but these to me are very top tier
episodes in in Star Trek whether it be
Voyage or either any of the other stuff
good episodes I think that's a good jump
into talking about
um the new track then because I think
this is what I'm talking about in some
of these episodes of new track are good
okay I'm not saying that all I'm not one
of these people that go all new track's
rubbish and some people say it's all
rubbish I'm not that no one of these
episodes are great I enjoyed the second
season discovery
discovered
yeah so
um uh the only episode I can really say
that I think
was powerful that did have that element
of hmm okay at the end of it I have to I
have to sit and think about this a
second was through the valley of the
Shadows which is the season two finale
when Pike basically has to
face up to his future and he's got a
choice basically where he can find out
what's going to happen or he can
um change it but then
somebody has you know basically somebody
has to die
um
I thought that was Anthony mantis's best
before you became a chef yes and started
cooking every five seconds
um this week on Star Trek I'm making a
lovely flambe why'd you Cisco used to
make jambalaya and all sorts of things
in DS9 not in everything
okay
um
but but that was a that was about and
actually I enjoyed that season even
though I thought at times it was a bit
stupid
um I and I I did enjoy the season and a
haul
um I
wish they hadn't done it in lots of ways
because I didn't want them to bring the
Enterprise into it but they did and the
way they did was okay
I gave a big higher role when we saw the
Enterprise fly at the end of season one
of Discovery and I thought no don't go
and also they redesigned it from the
original one I mean you know it's nice
the continuities never been in new track
they're about to reimagine it
re-visualize yeah I've got used to it
now
you know um I know we haven't really
sort of focus on Enterprise but when
they did them in a mirror Darkly the
two-part Mirror Universe episodes
um it was really clever because we saw
the defiant come back from the TOs
episode exactly how it looked and it
looked good the lighting was good even
though it's a you know very
old-fashioned design from the 60s they
made it look good and this is one thing
um with new Trek which I've got used to
but I had to take a while to get you so
that they they are now
re-visualizing Canon aspects of of
Starship between 2000 and well to 1966
to 2005 and that's one thing that I took
me a little while to adjust but that's
not really the top that's that's
slightly uh sort of off topic about the
best episodes
um
just remind me of it today just remind
me of a Deep Space Nine episode though
that I actually think maybe isn't top
tier but I think is in the conversation
because of how clever it was and I did
write it down and trials and trivial
trials and tribulations so they actually
went back and visited the trouble of
Tribbles episode yeah they actually went
back there was a lot of nostalgia it was
a lot of oh my God it's Captain Cook and
there's a lot of funny jokes I loved
some of the Klingon jokes and things in
there
um
but it was such a well done and clever
episode that it deserves to be in that
conversation and again
it's not something new track has ever
done
enterprised did it a couple of times and
I thought like you said the we were
going to get a whole season of The
Mirror Universe as well if we've got
season five we're gonna get virtually
season five
um there was talk about or very least
several episodes maybe they were like
kids season four they're like three or
four episodes clumped together in little
Arc or something like that yeah that we
were going to see more of it anyway so
um and we'd have we've got to see the
refit in Enterprise
we mentioned the final episode of
Enterprise though before we talk about a
new Trek again
if if that had been just a season finale
and not the series finale
I don't think it's a bad episode
do you know what the problem is it's a
see it's the series finale that's why I
always liked the episode I've always
liked it but I think that there was I
think it was called Terror Prime was the
two-parter before that and a lot of
people consider that like the even
though it wasn't it was more like the
series finale because it was the
beginning of the formation of the
Federation and then but to have the Next
Generation I heard all the actors were
really upset when this episode was
filmed because they didn't have Planet
they've got canceled
uh during the production of season four
and so they had to rush around and get
this C series finale and this is why it
wasn't done as well as most people would
have hoped
um as you say there have been a season
finale if season four and then it had a
season five I think it would have been
quite popular
um
it brought in Jonathan Frakes and Marina
circus and
um and I I and I could completely
understand the actors from the series so
like going no this is our show what the
hell are these guys doing well they're
just holidays one of them I was like
yeah it was a shame it was a shame that
they did it uh hugely but I think they
did it partly because it was the end of
18 years consecutive production of Star
Trek from 1987 to 2005 something like
that and I think this is partly why they
wanted to sort of bring what they've
created in Star Trek full circle under
the rickburn era um at that point
it's a shame but um I still enjoy it but
they should have killed a trip
well it's an argument to say that he's
not really dead but um
uh and you never know we may still get
to see there's massive rumors the
scopper coolers in season five of
discovery
or man you might be in strange new
worlds I I can't see that happening
somewhere quite strange new walls
um
yeah it'd be quite open he dies five
years before strange new worlds
um yes before but there is but you could
do a flashback where Anderson Mountain
as a slightly younger man meets him
because there's about 15 or 20 years
when Anthony was in the Federation where
Archer was still alive so there could be
something where we see him it's slightly
younger but um
yeah um do you expected I did Hollow
Deck episodes better than any other
series did yeah the TNT tend to get a
little bit of a habit of Something's
gone horribly wrong with the hollow deck
and we're all in trouble and it'll all
be okay
but the Moriarty episode
um with the Holodeck was brilliant yes
which um they had a sort of loose
connection in Picard as well the actor
came back which was nice to see
um I mean um well I'll just very quickly
say well I remember one of my favorite
DS9 episodes is an episode called hard
time with Bashir where he's in the
prison and he's been in this prison for
20 years he's given his memories and he
comes back and he's really scarred and I
was always been a big Brian fan I think
Colin mean is a great actor and
everything I've seen again and I've just
always thought that and again it's not a
top tier one but I just had to give the
episode a shout out because it's all
awesome so I suppose we should go back
to obviously
contemporary so I'm so sorry I will
disclaimer for one this is all about
opinion so when I'm talking when I'm
saying that I don't like some things I
don't like it so let's leave that there
um but because I've got my own YouTube
channel it means I'm right
for the um things of this conversation
anyway and now she's not this is a
conversation it's opinion
um I don't think any
of new track has got anywhere to the
heights of some of the episodes we've
just talked about
um
I said like through the valley of the
Shadows bloody good episode one or two
episodes of um strange new worlds have
been really really good
but not
that I would remember in 20 years and I
think that's the thing and I am not
comparing this to other shows at the
moment because I actually think strange
new world is one of the best sci-fi
shows on TV at the moment I really like
it it's a really solid series
um there's a lot and there's a good
there's a there's some really good
Sci-Fi on at the moment particularly
like apple and stuff that's really good
Sci-Fi foundations one yeah and I think
it's great
um
I just don't think if you compare it to
the the great episodes of the original
series
um TNG Voyager Deep Space Nine and even
some of the Enterprise episodes which
episode Enterprise like um did have some
great episodes broken bow on the first
two episodes I thought were brilliant I
loved regenerations there were some good
episodes yeah yeah yeah
um
what do you think that's India do you
like this in the art though in season
three I didn't hate it
um it kind of made sense following the
info and final 911.
um but but yeah no I didn't I didn't
hate it
um it was it was all right
um I thought it had some great episodes
and I thought it had some weak episodes
okay
um I just wish we'd at the end of that
Arc they would they'd have done the
refit then when the Enterprise was
battered and then I think we'd have got
a fifth season
yeah it's one of those things you always
sort of wonder what would happen if they
made a season five
um it's such a shame it's such a shame
but um but um I I do think that they
just needed I don't think they were far
they were getting great numbers they
just they just needed that little bit
extra to give it a give it a kick up
back so and I think something like the
um yeah that would have worked didn't
someone who worked at Paramount really
couldn't stand uh science fiction he was
really out against Star Trek anyway I
can't think about it I sit up here at
somebody uh wanted it gone
but that might have been something I
read it might have been something no one
of the top Executives at Paramount at
the time thought that Star Trek was all
science fiction to be fair was too
expensive okay um and it didn't get the
numbers and it but it was the sort of
the birth or it was sort of the height
of the popularity of like reality TV so
this is one executive the then left just
before new track was basically saying
why are we making this massively
expensive TV show where we can make this
other show for Pence and everyone
watches it down to ratings isn't it of
course it is yeah and so he even though
the ratings were good
it's it wasn't the same
um
so yeah
but I mean
somebody mentioned Memento Mori as as a
truly great episode of
um strange new worlds and that is the um
episode when we first sort of see the
corn attack and oh yeah yeah right in
and it's it's a horror episode yes
um I don't think that's it might be a
good episode it might be a fun episode
um it was it was scary even it was not a
great episode of Star Trek
um it's funny because I've made a list
of some of my favorite episodes of
Discovery Picard and strange new worlds
um and I I was trying to think of ones
to sort of say well look this is
you know this is on the level as we
wanted to talk about saying looking at
the list I've got some of my favorites
yeah I could see what you're saying
about the fact that um
but I mean the question is
right
but that's it bye-bye nice to be honest
um but what I was gonna ask is that if
you kind of like if you'd have watched
all of Star Trek now in 2023 obviously
take a lot of time to watch them all
rather than watching them whenever you
first watch Star Trek many many years
ago probably
would your perception of because there
was a big gap between 2005 and 2017 when
trick came back and Discovery started in
such a bad way an unrecognizable way
that it put it in a in a negative
context or do you think it is that the
writing is just simply just not as good
or as as you know as solid as it was in
the old days
I think there's an element I think one
of the things I honestly think is
because there's only 10 episodes
expectations are higher right so you
don't have the
um
you don't have chance to do like Filler
episodes each episode has got to be spot
on
and I think that's a problem when you've
got 24 episodes if only five of them are
brilliant
um that's although people will remember
those five episodes and they just get I
mean we've done a list here about 10 or
15 episodes from the original series
three series that we love but we're
talking about
700 something episodes of stars back yes
it is
um when you've got only we've only had
20 episodes of strange new worlds and I
can honestly say we haven't had a truly
classic episode
I'll accept the musical obviously I mean
duh
um I like the music at all it was good
no yeah um so
um no okay it's opinion but you're wrong
um
um so yeah
expectations are higher I keep saying
that like this is one of my irritations
with the musical Star Trek real estate
is very very valuable because we only
get 10 hours of it a year
um we may not even get 10 hours of it a
year for the next couple of years thanks
we may only get it might be we might not
get any Star Trek new Star Trek next
year season five live action oh well I
have to discover Steven five it might be
two years again until we get strange new
rules yeah I know I know
um so
you know the real estate is very very
valuable it's got to be better
and I think I just think expectations I
I actually don't think the writing
is bad
most of the time sometimes you do you do
I do wonder sometimes I wonder what are
they doing yeah
um like the first episode of second
season two and
um the pilot
his name is just going out my head I
love she's my favorite character
ah I forgot his name's gonna head with
the hair and the shaved things oh um
I'll take this
um so um she's good and she's given
Spock what's your thing
you know yeah yeah yeah yeah and Picard
said you know make it sir what's your
thing and and he and she forced him to
that and I'm like you've really got more
important things to think about right
now stop being stupid and I don't think
except in a couple of the movies I think
they did
um I'm thinking about
um in Star Trek
um when they face fight the face pulling
guys
um
some of the writing interaction was bad
um but generally speaking
I don't think the writing was much
better because it was so rushed as well
in TNG and stuff some of the writing was
pretty shoddy but we forget the really
bad episodes and we focus on the amazing
episodes but with the new track
even the discovery they've actually only
had 40 episodes of Discovery up till now
that's only two seasons of another
series actually I think they've had more
about about 50 55 because the first few
seasons are like season one was 15
episodes season two was 14 episodes okay
it's a bit more than that yeah but it's
even so as you say you know
yeah yeah it didn't get good until the
second season they've got basically 48
48 episodes under their belt before it
got good yeah
so what you're saying is that
potentially it might be a factor that
it's not exactly the whole fault it's
the nature of the fact that current Star
Trek they just make a lot less that and
of course in if you've got longer
episodes you're gonna get a lot more
chance at least something sticking and
becoming something really really good
okay it puts the pressure on each
episode to be really good and of course
not every episode is going to be really
good because that's the law of averages
because of the nature of the way that
they do stuff contemporary
but I would argue as well that because
they've the flip side of that coin is
though because they're only doing 10
episodes and they spend so much money on
an episode eight nine million dollars
and they didn't used to spend anything
like that on TNT before and they were
rushed you know they were writing
scripts were arriving at the actor's
doors the night before filming you know
they don't do that now they have a lot
longer to prepare those episodes should
be better should be better because
they've had a lot more yeah I can see
that yeah
it's not
um and even strangely well that I like
on the whole
I thought the first season ended quite
weekly I thought this season started
quite weekly but then picked up
um but on the whole I really like it I
like the characters
um the ship spins around a lot but other
than that it's a little bit irritated in
the first season there that one shot and
was so popular so they just keep doing
it
um and um it's getting a bit irritated
and the cooking the cooking's irritated
um but on the whole I really love the
show but I have to say my favorite Star
Trek at the moment is the animated
that's interesting because I I like the
animator I've only just finished season
three of lodex literally
um this last weekend
um and I like it I love the episode with
the deer whether it's DS9 I thought that
was a great crossover for some reason I
don't know why but animated stuff it
never seems to stick in my head so much
you never I I kind of watch it and I
like it but then I always find it a bit
forgettable and I don't know why why is
it because it's animated that's
interesting with me but it's just
something about it yeah and to be honest
it won't stick me forever but I I think
it's more tracky track gate makes a good
point now that the burn and uh season
three yeah I think one stupid I I
actually thought they were they were
really clever there put the discovery in
the future I'm like yes
I was really disappointed with that for
sure when they got there it didn't work
out for me at all and then yeah thanks
Philly we got into the future we saw all
this great technology and as a geek I
love the technology I love the ships and
they basically said the federation's
dead I'm like oh for God's sake
I mean you're so close and so they
ruined that for me so I actually haven't
seen a lot of season four
I might not watch season five
really
that's right
okay I'll give it a go I probably will
but it's probably going to be a TV show
that I put on in the background while
I'm working or something how can I do
that if my boss is watching I I just
focus on work
um I don't put TV on I haven't watched
our Tech I haven't watched all of
Stargate Atlantis in the last three
weeks
I'm not in the background
um are you gonna delete this this live
stream once he finishes there now
um yeah I'll just tell you I was lying
for comedy effect yeah yeah it was my
idea we sort of had this idea before we
before we end one that I was going to
say that one yeah yeah that's it's all
it's all very funny
but yeah so I mean
I said yeah I'll put it I'll give it
another go I'll give it another go
because there are a bit that I like but
there are my main problem with Discovery
though is the characters aren't very
good they're very forgettable
um the most interesting thing about
Burnham is that her first name's Michael
yeah and I like the um the tall dude
with the uh Sarah Sarah is uh is to me
the biggest Starship character in
Discovery uh yeah I think um the actual
place I think his name is really good
um and I I don't know whether he's I
think like I said they could have not
sort of like they could have developed
him a bit more but if the proper alien
sort of like looking at Humanity from a
different perspective kind of character
which is normally getting a startup
series and I think for what he's done
he's actually done quite well but yeah I
mean he's the strongest character for me
but the rest of the the um the
characters are a bit kind of like
forgettable really about how many books
I like that engineer they brought in
towards the end the um
so are the new track shows actually
getting new fans and having fans come
back generally speaking I say no not the
way they hope for a Paramount anyway the
fans of new track is interesting right
because I I've said a few times now
the fan base in Star Trek is divided and
I get I get people arguing with me no it
isn't no it isn't and I'm like no come
on I've got 26 000 subscribers now a lot
of my Star Trek fans are all sci-fi fans
I get a lot of comments and I see a lot
of negativity towards Star Trek as as
much as love towards it there's a
divided fan base but the numbers don't
lie a lot of people watch Star Trek it
does well it gets on the Nielsen top 10
rating regularly now which it did before
Discovery hasn't really ever done that
but the other new shows have
um and it does seem that Discovery in
particular has a quite a young
demographic it's got new trackies and
that's not a bad thing that's a great
way for that they're trying to get into
younger people to get involved with it I
think which is where Academy's going to
come from because they want to continue
that thing yeah but I actually would you
agree that the
trekkies traditional trekkies Branan
Braga us Trek is 40 something yeah they
are quite divided on Star Trek
absolutely I think that the most the
biggest unification of of our sort of
generation of Trek is it's been because
season three I think that I know that
you you you were okay with it I know you
obviously oh I loved it first time first
time absolutely adored it I then watched
it again and I'm like yeah but what I'm
saying is that whatever obviously
nothing's perfect I still think from
what they did bringing back all those
characters all the all the storylines
and loads of things from the last 30
years all sorts of things which then
when you watch the old show again
there are sort of further consequences I
I just still think that that did so well
for United and most people especially
the mcburman as holy trekkies kind of
thing
um I don't know how popular pecan's been
with the younger New Generation trackers
I would have thought some of them it
would be a bit over the heads because a
lot of the story lines they wouldn't
know about data and datum was once an
Android and now he's like a synthetic
and things like that you know it was
this Enterprise D thing you know and
it's like but
um again when he got a series which has
been going for heading towards 60 years
you're going to have generations of
trekkies and we all
um you know we're gonna like different
aspects of it it's such a big uh thing
now there's so many different there's 13
is it 13 movies and we've got about
eight live-action TV series we've got
about three animated series it's never
going to please everybody nothing well
the same as Ultra well they didn't no
you shouldn't try to no no so that's
what I'm saying same so um but I still
think with regard to us you know for me
Discovery is the I mean most people I
have to say this I think that most
people would wear the discovery is
probably one of the weakest live action
series again evil Enterprise isn't that
popular because surprise boats are quite
like that
um strangely Wells at least for me is
definitely more like you know satellite
episode track
um they've got a great Act of Atlanta
Mount they've got some great sort of
like Bridge crew and it works great
characters
play Spock is brilliant the bloopers
brilliant yeah yeah so um the Chapel's
great yeah so I think that you know
nothing's ever going to be 100
appreciated but I think that after the
real bad start Discovery season one I
think they've really course corrected
they've really looked to the early
mistakes and I look forward to what
comes next I'm not bothered about
section 31
um uh sort of the TV movie particularly
um it's just
the academy series it's again that's
going to be like Starship 90210 as far
as I can see and I'm I'm 50 years old so
it's a bit beyond my favorite Point
um please I'm gonna go into that with an
open mind but yeah
and Star Trek Legacy they can make that
with Tony metallis who I still think has
done so much in a positive way in the
last year or so um then that would be
that's what I'm hoping for please let's
get let's have strategy world's seven
seasons whatever whatever that be
um a Star Trek um uh Legacy sort of
thing with um maybe some of the bridge
through the Enterprise G and some
crossovers for the Next Generation 25th
Century era Shrek as well you know early
24 that era after all the stuff from
board to DS9 and TNG
that's what I'd like that here to
continue and get Crossovers and it's the
year it should be in that's the one yeah
[Music]
words
it's the problem strange the world is
that it's tied it's completely stuck in
continuity you know that spot's not
gonna die in The Next Episode because
he's you know that's the one thing
what's that do you first hit Jake that I
call in the Star Trek 90210 I actually
started a hashtag
I said that so what you've done like
that being said now I love it I I'm
pretty sure oh you like it oh sorry okay
but no new Trek fans hate that I'd keep
calling I keep saying it I get I do get
some um okay and I've just said it now
um yeah I'm pretty sure I started
um
as soon as I heard it I was just like
that sounds like Star Trek 902 when I
open it just stuck
um but um yeah it's um and it's new new
Trek fans yeah they moan at me for it I
don't care
um it's it's how I feel but I keep
saying I'm not gonna kill the show
before it comes out I will give it a go
because if it's got good characters and
well acted and well written it could be
great it depends what they then decide
to set it up as how how
how they decide to move forwards with it
but if it is just a setting like
basically the new Starfleet Academy and
them learning and keeping it it's oh I
think they're going to struggle making a
quality like Police Academy
police staffy Academy 90210
you're not going to be allowed back if
you keep saying stupid things
um
um don't and don't put it out loud there
because Alex Goodson might be watching
so don't put that up there okay okay I
don't put anything past them at the end
of the day Star Trek is new track Star
Trek original I think they're just
trying to make the best sci-fi show they
could yeah new track and I honestly
think this is the core of the problem
the new Trek
and they keep making shows of different
demographics so they've made Discovery
for a young or audience so early 20s
yeah yeah that's the demographic they
made card for us yeah
they made strange new worlds and they
tried to
maybe make that for us as well but
trying to go across the generations yeah
they made lower decks as a comedy
um show and again try to maybe go for a
younger audience and then they made
Prodigy for kids
um just make the best Star Trek show you
can make don't aim at a demographic just
make a Sci-Fi show that makes sense and
is a good Star Trek Sci-Fi show and if
it's good people will come
um you know and I I honestly think
that's a big problem with Star Trek is
that they have these metadata in their
head when they make it let's make a show
for these people because I know just
make the best show you can
they're very cautious and they they over
evaluate the way that they think a
series could be successful so this is
why you get these people who say well
look I should say let's make a series
for like
um people they're like like teens or
early 20s or you know as you say just
make good quality science fiction
storylines or Arts whatever but good
characters which should be
um enjoyable for people of all ages it's
like all the Picard f-bombs and stuff I
I thought myself I mean my kids are old
enough that they can watch it but if
they'd have been like five or six
um and they'd watched some of the other
series I wouldn't have let them see the
car because I wouldn't want them here in
that sort of bad language at a young age
and I think myself and I I never liked
swearing in Star Trek you know I know it
sounds like I don't like swearing as a
principal but you know you know it goes
back to like um you know the 21st
century where like um colorful metaphors
that Spock said because in the era of
Star Trek you didn't need to swear it
wasn't something you did very often and
they kind of I didn't like that
aspective once or twice I think when
data got his emotions and they're about
to crash and it just turns out yeah that
worked that was yeah that was that was
fine I did mine that one but I think
because it worked so well they then did
it in interaction
um
yeah yeah yeah and then he did this the
joystick and Atari joystick and and flew
the ship a three-dimension
three-dimensional space a joystick yes
well yeah bigger that out
um try and fly a plane with just one
joystick in CFA yeah
um but um the um so yeah they just
overdid it and then then yeah they made
extremists goes oh we swear great I
swear I didn't like that
it it brought it all down it didn't
didn't work
um
right okay my battery is about to die
because I've had to switch over to this
oh yeah all right okay thank you very
much and I think we've covered that I
think we're in agreement that I'm right
um
episodes actually I didn't show up
I'm all out but all the episodes I've
chose I don't think any of them stood up
given the examples of some of the top
two episodes we talked about on the
other Series tonight so
um
Fair reasons why that is yeah and that
it's not as simple as that it's just not
as good I do think there are you know
another day if you've got 900 something
episodes of Star Trek and some of them
are amazing and we just don't have that
yet we need track but I I honestly don't
think there are any new Trek episodes
that stand up to a couple of these
episodes we've talked about and I'm not
to shame but I think for me it's not
good we've had some good really good new
track just not that we've not quite had
that
great episodes of Star Trek uh I was I
was compare this to bands right so my
favorite band is the Foo Fighters oh
yeah yeah bone stony's t-shirt but I'm
actually I'm a booze fan the Foo
Fighters have never had
that like amazing single right they've
never had that like song that like
everybody knows like Nirvana before them
with Dave Grohl had Smells Like Teen
Spirit everybody knew it it was the song
of a generation almost
um Foo Fighters have never had that but
instead what they've done is they've
banged out eight out of 10 albums just
over and over and over again just good
albums
and just been consistently brilliant but
they've never had that stratospheric hit
right
new track just hasn't had that
stratospheric episode it just hasn't had
that episode that is just head and
shoulders above everything else at the
moment that people actually and even
though Picard season three was great I
loved it it's the most excited I've had
I've got about Star Trek in years I was
getting up early on a Thursday morning
to watch it
it wasn't great
they were it was good and it was only
the Nostalgia that excited me it was
only the Nostalgia I think it was one of
the highest levels that we've had in
neutral
I agree
I I did like a lot I haven't got that
excited about any of the other Star
Treks yeah that's not going out of my
way like literally just set my alarm in
the morning to watch it but you do you
think eventually we will get that top
tier or do you think that maybe the car
season three that's as good as it's
gonna get
I'm worried about what the plans are
okay I think section 31 could be
brilliant do you okay yeah I really
think that could be really really good
because there's so many possibilities
for that okay
um they could go anywhere with that
there's completely there's no there's no
handcuffs they could do anything so it
could be astonishing
um they've got a really good director
and the writers are excellent so I think
they could do something really really
good with that okay
um
I'm very worried about Star Trek 90210
um and I'm very worried they might not
do Legacy I'm very worried about strange
new worlds to be honestly it's the right
to strike I think if this wasn't going
then I think we'd have it on confidence
as to what potentially is going to be
coming up but with all this uncertainty
I mean I think we're all worried about
anything really coming up you know
there's nothing certain so well the
rumor I've heard more than once now from
a couple of sources in and around
Paramount is that strange new worlds
will end after season three and we'll
get Legacy
um in a way I hope they don't do that
but it would explain why they've brought
Kirk in so early
oh
okay that makes sense yeah but basically
apparently the plan was always for three
seasons
like
um because they were aware that the
closer they get to the original series
The more complicated it gets and the
more they'll be inhibited because of
continuity with the Future Okay well
they've obviously shown that already
that they do not give a flying F about
continuity
they don't care hello they're gone yes
exactly yeah yeah well like I say Kirk
coming in as he has done
how many more I I joked about this the
other week how many more excuses are
they going to come up with a Kirk to
appear on that ship is it going to be
like his turn I've got I've left my keys
I can't remember my kids it's there to
see his brother though isn't he he don't
want to see his bro but he's not
supposed to know Pike
Abrams movies that made them friends and
made a mentor and it's like kurtzman
thinks that I actually do Wonder a
strange new worlds is kurtzman Star Trek
and it's not it's actually a different
Universe oh yeah I mean people say that
some people say that it's the Borg
sphere that went back in time uh from
um Nemesis that caused a slightly
different alternate timeline and people
are all saying so lots of things but it
doesn't matter it's because it's because
the timelines are screwed up it's all
messed up still good starter but as a
Trekkie it irritates me
um you know it's like so but anyway
oh God love it um let's have you back on
Mike in a week or two let's talk some
Stargate we were talking about it before
we came on live and we'll have a bit of
a recap um
absolutely I've got um I'm talking
Stargate at the weekend with uh with
somebody new that um I've I've come
across but but let's let's get you back
on in a couple of weeks and talks love
to come back thank you that'd be great
look forward to it and um and as an idea
for your podcast why don't you do am
Stargate episode and I'll come on
Stargate video and I'll come over do you
know we've reviewed all the episodes all
the actual uh specific series but we
could do a compilation of all just
Stargate as it is yeah come back in the
movie have you done the movie no we
haven't done the movie let's do the
movie right okay we'll sort something
out definitely
um guys everyone in the comments thank
you so much I apologize again that my um
internet let us down a little bit
halfway through then I had to switch to
my phone but um these things happen when
you've got teenagers about computer
games and don't go to bed when they're
told tell me about it tell me about it
what are you gonna do
um some point I will get better internet
but no thank you so much and Mike um
tell us about the solo one podcast
quickly where we can find you uh yes
we're on uh YouTube my channel is called
code it's quite popular 150k Subs we
talk about all sorts of Science Fiction
TV series movies and just come along and
just have a laugh and just just talk and
talk so come come over and check us out
we will do so um are you 150 000 now
well nearly but about about 800 away
yeah we were only you're only like 100
over 100k when we first started chatting
that's not been that long so you've gone
off
thanks to you I think you know I'm very
welcome if you could put a link on your
community page to my channel
not bad not bad at also but yeah you
work hard on these channels and it's
nice when it pays off it is absolutely
because there's a lot of people working
very hard on YouTube and they and never
get anywhere thanks to the way the
YouTube works so yeah now you should be
proud of your little blue square that
you got I will never get one and I'm
okay with it you'll get one
um no man honestly if I got 100 000
subscribers I would [__] to myself every
time
well and of course that in the future
well if like I say if over like a
thousand people I've had I've had um 300
people watching a live a video Once live
and we're talking about style getting
stuff and it went up to 300 and oh man I
just kept yeah
is actually 300 people watching me right
now oh my god
um I mean there's 30 people watching us
right now which isn't bad at all yeah we
get over 100 regular but 300 people
watching is stressful
um I just have to not look at it but
but um if I got like 10 000 people
watching a video I'd be just like don't
make a mistake don't make a mistake
don't make mistake
maybe you never know but at 50k I've got
to get a tattoo I want a hundred
thousand K I said I'd strip
so
that's really happening next to you
don't don't maybe don't share the
channel
anyway Mike thank you so much mate have
a lovely evening we'll see you in a
couple of weeks and we'll talk some star
game guys thank you so much everybody
see you soon